I have a question oh what is your name
my name is Haley Haley how are you uh
I'm good how are you guys I'm good this
is so surreal seeing you guys live you
guys are just as funny as in person as
you are on audio tape so this has been
so cool
audio you talk like me yeah I don't know
why I said that yeah
the young ones
send it out via post immediately oh my
gosh
well uh my question for all of you guys
is so Norm McDonald is easily one of my
favorite comedians of all time
um I yeah he's phenomenal so do you guys
have any favorite like bits moments or
memories that he's ever done like I know
he's known for so many of his viral
Clips but just I know some you knew him
on a personal level so just anything
that you remember uh one of the things
that I remember that Norm did I don't
think many people know about but I think
you can find it if you look it was so
Random normally just do these random
things and so
um Sully sullenberger the pilot famously
his planes taking off in New York one of
the engines goes out because I think
there's a bird strike and he or
something goes wrong and he lands it on
the Hudson River and everyone gets off
safely and he you know he's got this
mustache and he he's cool and he saved
everybody and everybody got Sully
sullenberger fever and then uh not for a
long time but anyway
um
but uh then I think Tom Hanks made a
movie yeah and then Norm came on and he
had this idea that he wanted to make you
know the it's too bad I produced a Sully
sullenberger movie before he safely
landed the plane and and I'm like this
was his idea and he made this so he came
on and he had shot it
and it was total lie but he's like yeah
that's something I'm kind of mad about
that sullenberger guy and I said what
are you mad about well I made a movie
with him before he did that and why'd
you do that I just chose a pilot and I
made a movie with him and then he goes
and does this thing and it's really just
selling Burger it's Norm playing silly
son and he grabbed our makeup woman Deb
Pullman and said you're going to be in
it too as my wife
literally while he's in the makeup chat
[Music]
too when she's
like even change she's just wearing the
clothes she wore to work and so he's
going like all right buddy it's your
captain uh Sully sullenberger and we're
gonna now land the plane uh oh who's
here my wife's here and Deb
walked in and went Hi how are you I love
you too dear and then she left and he
was like all right here we go and we've
landed so uh there you go I think we're
all good and then the credits came down
it was the randomest weirdest idea and
he made it and you can see it go look
for it and it was one of these things
that's not you know it never trended or
whatever but it's just out there and you
just see Norm my favorite thing he did
as a comedian was intentionally waste
people's time
and it was
he didn't care in this beautiful way
because people
he and
it's glorious and I look at it now and I
just see him doing this bit
and think wow I mean no one else would
do that no one else would make that up
grab the makeup woman make her be his
wife and not give a and then leave
and it was really funny so that was my
favorite